as long as we've been together
kumara has always searched for the
deepest connections
[Music]
and today
we would like to share that experience
to you oh my God are they gonna have sex
in front of us
ayahuasca
plant-based medicine
that takes you on a life-shifting
journey if you allow it
today our Shaman Bobo hizon is here to
help facilitate that process
ing his name as well
[Music]
trust me when when I first tried it I
was I was nervous and skeptical but when
I say it's the [__] we got it we got it
I'm in
uh I'm in two I'll grab the seat next to
uh to Shelly right babe you in I'm down
I'm down
uh I I don't know this stuff is kind of
out there and hell I need to get in the
chicken ready
let us begin
[Music]
yeah yeah fill her up I got this yeah
you lied to me really Bobo Bobo hizon is
my name is Sarah
I promise you the plant will reveal all
your troops
you may drink
so we update I will or
[Music]
I'll
I'm okay
[Music]
oh
it's too much
this will never do
I'm just gonna poison a [__] oh such a
cop-out you little [__]
[Music]
oh [__] [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
where you at
listening
[Music]
you knew you were gonna see me today
didn't you
insane since you arrived
I [__] love
the way that you say my name
Candace can you move
I can feel things but I can't move
anything
find me you find yourself
reveal me to those who cannot see wisdom
is everywhere
even our plans our wisdom Keepers plants
are Healers
[Music]
[Applause]
we ignore healers they
will you wake them
and I'm
I'm trying to climb this ladder
[Music]
yes yes I will awaken them
are you having an orgasm without me
foreign
[Music]